corona nervt und weil es so nervt sagen
uns regierungspolitiker immer wie toll
wir das alles machen gerade auch im
vergleich mit anderen ländern was man
hier kriegen wir corona gut hin ich bin
thomas reichert und korrespondent im zdf
hauptstadtstudio bevor war ich fünf
jahre lang studioleiter des zdf in
peking
ich kenne also beide welten ost und west
ziemlich gut und ich finde im vergleich
zu asien bekommen die korona überhaupt
nicht gut hin
wir schauen heute mal drauf woran das
liegt ob diktaturen ein virus besser
beherrschen können dass demokratien und
am ende
verrate ich euch fünf gründe warum asien
das irgendwie besser hinkriegt als wir
im moment erinnert ihr euch noch an die
korona dem um mit den november als
störer sogar den bundestag reinkam mit
hilfe der afg und abgeordnete bedrängten
an lebt tagen meldete das lka das
robert-koch-institut über 300 corona
tote und ich wurde von den protestlern
beschimpft weil ich eine maske trug an
dem tag hört dich jens spahn im
reichstag sagen wir sind meine damen und
herren bis hierhin gut durch die krise
gekommen
vergleichsweise auch mit der situation
länder für mich passen das alles
irgendwie nicht zusammen die einen
leugneten die solche obwohl über 300
menschen daran sterben und auf der
anderen seite war der
gesundheitsminister der trotz der
erschreckend hohen todeszahlen sagte wir
könnten uns jetzt wirklich mal auf die
schulter klopfen wo wären sie eigentlich
viel weiter in der bundesrepublik
deutschland das leben
stimmt schon keines unseren
nachbarländern da dachte ich mir in dem
moment aber was ist eigentlich mit china
meine freunde dort erzählten mir es gibt
überhaupt keinen lockten er keine
sperrstunden und die restaurants sind
wieder offen wie kann das sein
was machen wir falsch und die richtig
kann china mit dem virus besser umgehen
weil es eine diktatur ist weil es eben
alles beherrscht sogar ein virus fangen
wir mal mit den nackten zahlen ok ich
habe als china- korrespondent gelernt
dass man offiziellen zahlen immer mit
viel misstrauen begegnen muss aber die
grobe richtung die ist schon klar in
deutschland sind umgerechnet auf die
einwohnerzahl 50 mal mehr menschen
gestorben heißt mit china
50 mal mehr woran liegt das wir müssen
dazu erst mal an den anfang der panini
gehen nach handeln diese elf millionen
stadt da ist das virus zunächst wird es
verschwiegen dann bricht es aus und
china macht einen harten lockt dann
wirklich hat führt über 70 tage dürfte
kaum auf straße und schon gar nicht die
stadt verlassen wie gesagt elf millionen
stadt abgeriegelt seitdem behauptet
china
das ist alles richtig gemacht hat im
kampf gegen des corona virus ja mehr
noch dass chinas diktatur ein vorbild
für die welt so wie es china gemacht hat
sowie seine diktatur macht so muss es
die welt machen sagt peking chongqing
stimmt dass das ist die weltkarte der
kurve 19 fälle von der johns hopkins
universität in den usa
und da sieht man als interessant dass es
gibt einen corona graben zwischen ost
und west in den usa in europa gibt es
große blasen die sich bedrohlich
überlagern das sind die infektionen dort
und in asien
das sind die blasen verkleinert aber
jetzt kommt was interessantes es ist
nicht nur china wo die blasen klein sind
in südkorea in japan in taiwan
das sind keine diktaturen das sind
demokratien erinnert ihr euch an unsere
ausgangsfrage schaffen diktaturen es
besser das virus zu beherrschen dass
demokratien nein das ist keine frage von
diktatur der demokratie asien hat es
offenbar besser hingekriegt das wir
aber woran liegt das zunächst mal nicht
am wetter ich habe nirgendwo so gefroren
wie in südkorea
wenn ich in peking zum skifahren
gegangen bin das kann man dort ein
bisschen im norden dann musste ich mich
einstellen auf temperaturen von minus 19
-20 grad also am wetter liegt es nicht
dass asien ist besser macht
das liegt zuallererst mal an uns selbst
und unsere mischung aus arroganz und
behäbigkeit mit der wir diesen virus
verändern anfang begegnet sind das ist
das institut das für die bekämpfung des
virus verantwortlich ist das hat am
anfang medizinern sogar verboten vorher
tote zu obduzieren um herauszufinden was
das virus mit dem körper macht das ist
ungefähr genauso ihre mit den leuten zu
sagen dass atemmasken gegen eine
ausbreitung des virus nichts bringen das
schlimmste was passieren könnte wenn das
tragen der maske dazu führt dass man
sich in einer falschen sicherheit wiegt
wobei irgendwann haben sie es dann
gelernt und haben ihre richtlinien
geändert
immerhin der dritte grund warum asien es
besser macht war der sommer merkel und
die ministerpräsidenten wollten uns die
ferien nicht vermiesen
das war nett aber dann lang war chaos
konnte ja niemand damit rechnen dass
diejenigen die in urlaub fahren dann
auch wieder zurückkommen oder keller
hinweis darüber dass wir mitte zu hause
bleiben sollen oder sowas nur dass wir
jetzt 24 stunden warten bis das ergebnis
also ich muß montag wieder arbeiten
eigentlich eigentlich aber ich kann ja
jetzt nicht nicht hofer dann
morgen mal anderen tag was ich machen
soll wichtig ist so ziemlich alles was
in asien gut funktioniert haben wir
nicht gemacht zb temperatur screenings
in den meisten ländern in asien sind
tests und quarantäne bei der einreise
auch kann ihn quasi freiwillige sache so
wie bei uns nein so bewusst in eine
quarantäne einrichtung ein hotel oder
irgendetwas anderes und die schauen
danach für 14 tage und es ist richtig
teuer die muss dafür zahlen das ist
nicht nur in diktaturen so sondern auch
in demokratien aber fast noch wichtiger
in asien wird jede infektion sofort
verfolgt und bei uns bei uns werden
jetzt sogar die tests knapp und die
gesundheitsämter sind total überlastet
weil sie zu wenig personal haben obwohl
die bundeswehr ihnen hilft kein wunder
in den gesundheitsämtern arbeiten sie
meistens noch mit papier oder
ausgedruckten excel-tabellen warum ist
nicht alles digital vernetzt sowie in
asien zum beispiel irgendwie würde das
nicht eingeführt irgendjemand hat sich
vielleicht nicht verantwortlich dafür
gefühlt jedenfalls wir haben keins punkt
asien china taiwan japan südkorea
die können solchen weil sie solchen
kennen ein freund von mir in südkorea
hat sich vor kurzem bei mir gemeldet und
hat gesagt die serien das nervt dass das
was in asien gelernt wurde von uns
überhaupt nicht wahrgenommen wurde
ihn treibt das total um weil er halb
koreaner ist und seine eltern in
deutschland sind und er die
infektionszahlen von ihr hört aber ist
es wirklich viel besser in südkorea
ich rufe ihn an und wir fragen ihn mal
hallo daniel wie gehts hier
wir haben jetzt die zweite welle bei uns
und die zahlen gehen durch die decke
in südkorea ist das überhaupt nicht so
warum woran liegt das aus deiner sicht
[Gelächter]
und selbst unter diesen umständen
gestiegen freizeit ist es so dass die
glaube lediglich 50 prozent der stellen
nur 15 können nicht verfolgt weil das
heißt 85 findet man und kann sie sofort
isolieren richtig was wir auch halten
ist das sehr praktisch wenn restaurant
geht oder mit listen der mittlerweile
funktioniert das meistens über die
sitzung zu machen also erwarte dass
endlich mal dann kann die gewerkschaften
die zu geben weil es ist und wenn du
jetzt wellen könntest während der korona
zeit wärst du lieber in deutschland oder
regiert wie jetzt in südkorea
du machst du dir sorgen um dann hätten
seine eltern in deutschland weil du
findest sie kriegen es nicht so gut hin
endlich also damit belegt deutschland
täglich um die 20.000 und auch um meiner
stadt eine richtig dank dieser soll
daniel vielen dank das ist doch jetzt
echt interessant in südkorea haben sie
maximal 500 infektionen bei uns gab es
zwischenzeitlich über 20.000 und sie
kriegen das in den griff nicht indem sie
einen harten locker machen wie in china
sondern dem sie früh und konsequent
reagieren und auch dabei bleiben
irgendwann im sommer muss uns wohlstand
individualisten
der sinn der für abhanden gekommen sein
dass man diese corona pandemie nur
gemeinsam hinkriegen kann aber das
wissen das man im zeit weil sie dann auf
grundrechte verzichten muss hat wirklich
nichts mit einer diktatur zu tun oder
wie die afg behauptet seine corona
diktatur ehrlich gesagt ich habe fünf
jahre als china- korrespondent in einer
diktatur gelebt das was wir im moment
erleben hat 0,0 damit zu tun das hat
eher damit zu tun dass wir uns gemeinsam
am riemen reißen
silvester ist wieder so eine sache klar
wäre es schön deine große party jetzt zu
feiern aber die gefahr ist doch dass wir
den gleichen fehler machen wie im sommer
dass wir dann wieder die bälle haben
wieder eine infektion
denn was sich jetzt zeigt wer corona
schnell besiegt und dabei bleibt der
kommt auch wirtschaftlich viel schneller
wieder auf die beine
china hat im dritten quartal erhebliche
zuwachsraten während in südkorea ist die
stelle durch corona in diesem jahr total
gering fiel geringer als bei uns warum
weil sie kronen griff kriegen und weil
sie weiter darauf achten ich habe euch
fünf gründe versprochen warum essen ist
deswegen kriegt und das sind sie erstens
die haben corona sehr ernst genommen und
haben sofort und entschieden darauf
reagiert zweitens alle länder haben
strenge einreise und quarantäne
drittens sie können die infektion genau
verfolgen und können jeden coroner brand
hat sofort isolieren viertens die wahl
apps in asien sammeln mehr daten aber
sie sind natürlich auch viel effektiver
und fünftens der wichtigste punkt die
bevölkerung macht mit
wenn die eigentlich spaßbremsen sind
doch die die dafür sorgen dass dieses
virus immer wieder aufflammt und wie
dann doch wieder in den neuen lockdown
hineinkommen
in asien ist es anders und deswegen
können wir viel von asien lernen aber es
ist eben gerade keine frage von diktatur
der demokratie sondern ist eine
extremsituation für jede gesellschaft
und die frage wie gut sie damit umgeht
hängt damit zusammen wie gut man
zusammensteht und wie sehr man bereit
ist von anderen zu lernen aber sagt mir
was ihr denkt was glaubt ihr ist der
wichtigste punkt was nervt euch am
meisten in corona maßnahmen und was
müsste aus eurer sicht passieren und
wenn es euch gefallen hat macht einen
leicht darunter und abonniert unseren
kanal denn inside politics gibt es jetzt
häufiger mit allem was in berlin so
passiert mit dem blick hinter die
kulissen
wir freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten mal dabei sein